hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast epstein-barr virus infections
pay me now or pay me later my name is
dr. Tiffany McKenzie and I am a
scientific affairs manager of infectious
disease and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots in sponsored by
the asan dia Sauron is a global leader
in the field of biotechnology for more
than 40 years the company has been
developing producing and commercializing
reagent kits for in vitro diagnostics
worldwide it offers the broadest range
of specialty tests available in the
immuno to diagnostics market and
continually invests in research and
development using its own distinctive
expertise in the field of immuno
Diagnostics to deliver a high level of
innovation for more information please
visit the IA s o rin calm now before we
begin we have a few important
announcements first this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit your questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button in the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions live as we can second
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
and finally if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem to the green Q&A button in the
lower left and finally I would like to
remind you that this is an educational
set webinar and this offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on CE e
button located in the bottom left corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to induce introduce today's speaker
dr. Hank Balfour who is a professor of
pediatrics in the division of infectious
diseases and professor of laboratory
medicine and pathology he also serves as
principal principal investigator of
clinical biology programs dr. Balfour is
recognized internationally as an expert
in the diagnosis and treatment of herpes
virus infections especially those due to
EBV dr. Balfour received his medical
degree from Colombia in 1966 completed
his internship and residency at the
University of Minnesota and Columbia
Presbyterian Medical Center in 1968
served as a pediatrician in the Air
Force at wright-patterson Air Force Base
in Dayton Ohio from 1968 to 1970 and
then completed a postdoctoral fellowship
in infectious disease at the University
of Minnesota in 1972 he has been at the
University of Minnesota faculty ever
since and he is board certified in
pediatrics it is now my pleasure to turn
it over to my friend dr. Hank Val for
for his presentation thank you very much
Tiffany and thank you for spending the
time all of you out there to participate
in our webinar today which is focused on
epstein-barr virus and the many diseases
that this virus is responsible for our
learning objectives are to help all of
us evaluate the clinical findings and
the laboratory tests used to diagnose
epstein-barr virus infections we will
discuss the probable mechanisms of EBV
spurred cancers and autoimmune diseases
and finally assess approaches to the
prevention of EBV infections
first I'd like to introduce you to my
laboratory and my laboratory group we
have a Jen Grimm on the Left Max
Schmeling on the right and then in the
middle is actually the oldest member of
our laboratory and that's Epstein Barr
virus itself and I say oldest because
this virus has been with us human beings
for millions of years and as such it has
adapted some very clever strategies to
avoid our immune surveillance system and
this is a close-up of the virus and one
of the interesting things about this
virus is that it has little surface
projections like that you may think
their ears of this creature but they're
what they actually are is is material
called glycoprotein the most expressed
material on this virus is GP 350 or
bright blue protein 350 which is a
target for immunization that we'll talk
about in a little bit this virus
connection this one is actually able to
talk and it says you can pay me now or
pay me later this really refers to a
series of commercials that the fram oil
filter company put out in the 70s and
80s and the point is here this mechanic
is saying you could pay me now or pay me
later and what he means is if you change
your oil filter regularly you won't have
to pay a large sum to have your engine
rebuilt later on well this I think is
kind of an interesting way to look at
EBI because a question that we ask is
are you better off getting primary EBV
infection when you're younger or when
you're older and this is a fascinating
unanswered question some would say
earlier because pre-adolescent children
don't commonly come down with mono they
have a relatively mild illness
whereas adolescents and adults usually
have full-blown model but some would say
you're
getting it later because a fairly recent
multinational study showed that children
with MS were significantly more likely
than matched controls to be infected
with EBV also in Africa among Kenyan
infants younger age at the time of
primary EBV infection was associated
with higher levels of EBV viremia that
persisted throughout infancy leading the
investigators to speculate that these
infants were at higher risk for endemic
birth
ofoma which is a disease clearly due to
EBV so are you better off getting
primary EBV when you're younger or when
you're older what do you think and at
the end of this webinar I will suggest
that there might be an alternative
answer the outline for this presentation
is listed here we'll first talk about
history because I think history is
always a good way to get a perspective
on where we are today so we'll talk
about the discovery of EBV and it's
connection with infectious mononucleosis
next we'll discuss a little bit about
the epidemiology of primary EBV
particularly among college students and
its clinical manifestations we will then
discuss the laboratory evaluation of EBV
and the staging of EBV diseases next
we'll talk about EBV associated diseases
or spurred diseases cancer and multiple
sclerosis being the main ones and
finally we will talk about prevention of
EBV infections so history begins in a
way in the 1880s when a pediatrician and
I'm glad it was a pediatrician because
I'm a pediatrician by the name Emil Phil
etaf described the syndrome and called
it idiopathic a tinnitus and from his
pointing of that term until 1967 the
etiology of infectious mononucleosis was
not established the next historical
landmark occurred in 1920 when two
doctors at Johns Hopkins universe
he described a condition that they
coined the term infectious mononucleosis
and that stuck and the important thing
was that this disease really could be
mistaken for early acute leukemia which
of course was totally untreatable in
those days the next important landmark
in the saga is that doctors here at the
University of Minnesota described the
cells that were very typical in the
peripheral blood of individuals
suffering with infectious mononucleosis
and we contrast the normal mature
lymphocyte on the left with these large
so-called downy named after hal dowdy
downy type 2 lymphocytes they're large
two to three times bigger than a normal
mature lymphocyte they have very
generous nuclear material and they have
a kind of a pale bluish cytoplasm then
in 1932 at Yale University the discovery
was made of the heterophile antibody
test and I want to stress that Hedera
file means something that is not related
to the causative agent and so a
heterophile antibody test which is a
very good way to do point-of-care
diagnosis of mono which is really
measuring our antibodies against the
mammalian red blood cells particularly
horse sheep or goat red blood cells is
not specific for for EBV and that is one
of the problems with the heterophile
test although it does remain the
mainstay in many many situations to make
the diagnosis of acute EBV infection the
story of the discovery of the virus is a
later story than that of the discovery
of the disease entity and it began in
1957 when Denis Burkitt who was a
pediatric surgeon assigned to Africa
during World War two
stayed and continued to practice his
surgical skills and discovered a disease
that we now know is Burkitt lymphoma
which was a jaw tumor of of children and
frequently fatal he went to the United
Kingdom to talk about this and in the
audience was Tony Epstein who heard
Dennis talk and then later arranged to
get some cells from him some of these
Berkut cells and and see if he could
discover if there was a virus in it and
sure enough in 1964 the the team that
Tony led was able to show that the
Burkitt lymphoma cells contained a virus
which was looked like a herpes virus and
was subsequently found to be a member of
but not the same as herpes simplex a
member of the herpes virus family EBV
the three individuals who published this
landmark paper or Tony Epstein himself
were not Chong who is a Irish
neurologist in Yvonne bar and the
message to those of you out there who
are contemplating a research career and
want to get on in research it's very
important not to be the middleman
because this is epstein-barr virus not
Epstein Tong and Barr virus then a sir
Antipodes event occurred the Henley's of
Aaron Aaron Gertrude who worked at
Children's Hospital in Philadelphia had
requested some of the Berkut cells
looking at at exactly what they were and
if they could perhaps get some method of
growing them in the laboratory and they
were using a blood from a technician who
in the course of a number of experiments
when her cells were combined with the
Berkut cells nothing happened but then
she contracted mono and after she came
back to the laboratory her cells were
totally permissive for viral replication
and this was a key clue that
at EBV caused infectious mononucleosis
which was later clearly established and
published in 1968 so now let's turn our
attention to the epidemiology and
clinical manifestations of primary EBV
infection we have been conducting a
series of prospective studies at the
University of Minnesota starting back in
2002 and one of the reasons to do
prospective studies of course is that
you have no idea what the natural course
of a disease is unless you take all
comers that is all of a certain
population that have never seen EBV
before our EBV naive and follow them
until they either leave your your study
or become infected with EBV and so what
we did was to recruit in the residence
halls of the University of Minnesota
shown here and and published in the 2013
a study that showed exactly what happens
if you follow college freshmen
throughout the four years of their
undergraduate experience
we actually had over 500 freshmen
screened for EBV prior infection and we
screened them by antibody against viral
capsid antigen and epstein-barr nuclear
yet agenda we'll talk about those
antigens and antibodies against them in
the context of how to stage evening the
infection and how to diagnose various
forms a little later on more than a
third actually 37% were EBV naive and of
those we enrolled 143 in surveillance
and saw them for as long as four years
over the period of surveillance there
were 66 primary EBV infections and the
interesting thing was and this is
essentially new news at that time 59 of
the infections or darn near ninety
percent were symptomatic so the textbook
statement that you know ten or twenty
five percent of subjects actually get
infected or sick is wrong it's more of
the majority and how does this
acquisition occur what we're looking at
here is a kaplan-meier graph or a life
table analysis and it starts out that
all of the people are EBV naive so
that's one point zero up there at the
top left corner
everybody is EBV naive and then during
the course of college we see a Stanley
downward trend which means individuals
are getting infected as they go along
the interesting thing is that in the
freshman year we had an infection rate
of 26 cases per hundred person years of
observation or 26% whereas in subsequent
years sophomore junior and senior we had
a rate of only 10% which has a very
small p-value it was quite significant
so that the major amount of acquisition
was occurring in the freshman year and
we can kind of understand that because
these kids are very liberated from their
home environment and our sort of
exploratory and so then we said well how
are they actually getting infected are
they getting infected from from the use
of various substances from different
diets the only thing we could find when
we assess the number of risk factors was
that deep kissing was the key to
acquisition of primary EBV among college
freshmen and this is what we call our
histogram where we're looking at three
different situations we're looking at
individuals who reported to us during
the course of the study that they had no
kissing or sexual activity individuals
who reported deep kissing only and then
those who said that they were sexually
active and the difference here is very
interesting we called those that said
they had no kissing or sexual activity
bookworms and the other ones are either
kissing only or sexually active the
difference between these populations
there's no difference
between kissing only and kissing with
penetrative sexual intercourse but
there's a difference for both of them
quite significant versus no kissing or
sexual activity and so it's pretty darn
clear to us that kissing with or without
sexual intercourse is the way that motto
is spread so it truly truly is the
kissing disease and talking about the
kissing disease let's see what we
actually find as far as signs and
symptoms are concerned well the top list
here is is a list of signs which really
means that these are things that you can
see on a physical examination and then
the lower cluster is symptoms that the
patient would report to you and one of
the one of the things that I want to
point out here is that almost all the
subjects when you examine them have a
red throat that's pharyngitis and have
lymph gland enlargement particularly of
the posterior cervical nodes and the
nose kind of the nodes kind of behind
the ears for the posterior auricular
nodes then um there are a couple of
findings that are unusual but represent
almost diagnostic for mono and these are
eyelid edema and and rash is notably
absent except when individuals are given
penicillin derivatives this is an
eighteen-year-old who is coming to us on
the third day of infectious mono and you
can see that he almost has his throat
obstructed with two things a very large
tonsil and now as we look a little
closer he has a large tonsil and it's
kind of almost stuck to this right here
which is his uvula and we have seen
some patients uvulas that are so swollen
and enlarged they look like a snake and
patient would almost choking him you can
imagine he was extremely uncomfortable
this is day three now on day eight he
still has a red beefy throat with some
pustular eggs eggs a date and the uvula
is still enlarged these pictures
indicate to you that infectious
mononucleosis is not a nice disease it's
a nasty disease talking about one of the
findings which of its presence is
pathognomonic that means that it's a
clear relationship to a specific disease
is the facial puffiness and eyelid edema
that that we do see occasionally right
there
and there just it was a subject that I
cared for what I was pediatrician at
wright-patterson Air Force Base in
Dayton Ohio and here's somebody who came
to see me just a few months ago I asked
her if she wanted me to cover her eyes
for this presentation she said no she
said I'm so distorted that nobody could
ever recognize me you see the facial
puffiness and you can see the eyelid
edema very very typical of infectious
mononucleosis and so what have students
all together in our prospective studies
over the years taught us about
epstein-barr virus infection first of
all the attack rate of EBG among college
freshmen is about 25% not not any any
less than that and when they get
infected three-quarters of them are sick
with a median duration of illness of 21
days that's a long time the major route
of transmission among adolescents and
young adults is deep kissing we also
have found in these studies that you can
detect the virus and you could detect
antibody against it in the mouth and the
bloodstream before the onset of symptoms
during the incubation period which we
believe is approximately 6 weeks because
of the high attack rate college freshmen
ideal subjects for a prophylactic
vaccine trial that we're going to
discuss a little bit later on we're
going to turn now specifically to the
laboratory evaluation of EBV infection
and I want to emphasize at this point
that this is an ongoing investigation in
other words we still don't have
necessarily the perfect answer to what
tests to use and when to apply them to
completely sort out the timing and the
types of EBV disease I'm going to show
you some material from a textbook that
has recently been published by the
American Society for Microbiology called
the manual of molecular and clinical
laboratory immunology and this comes
from a chapter that we wrote and it
looks at the recommended laboratory
tests for the diagnosis and management
of EBV infection simplifying it to
looking for past infection in other
words immune status or detection of very
early or subacute disease and what we're
recommending here is that for past
infection
VCA IgG antibody is the single best test
because virtually all of the subjects
that we've studied who have acquired
primary EBV infection under our
surveillance are VCA IgG antibody
positive Aetna one antibody is a good
test too but if no one is not made by a
hundred percent of subjects three to
five percent never make it no one for
reasons that we don't totally understand
but that's the case for the detection of
primary EBV infection I think that the
heterophile test is probably the most
widely used and we recommend it with
caveats the caveats are that young
children particularly those under the
age of four often do not make
heterophile antibody and so their
heterophile negative and you could miss
model in those circumstances then also
it takes sometimes seven to ten days for
the heterophile to turn positive where
the VCA IgM
is frequently positive right at the
onset of infection
so that's your alternative test for
subacute infection we recommend a
combination of VCA IgM and VCA IgG those
should be positive for subacute
infection that basically is infection
say after the first three months but
before a year after onset of the primary
epstein-barr virus infection now here we
have a display of both viral activity
symptoms peripheral blood material and
an antibodies first thing I want to
point out is oral shedding
oral viral shedding with EBV
begins before onset of symptoms non set
of symptoms are shown here in gray and
then persists intermittently for many
many years and we think frequently the
source of primary EBV infection for a
naive person is kissing somebody who is
completely asymptomatic but who is
experiencing intermittent oral viral
shedding another point to be made here
is that the very Mia period is fairly
short shown here and the VCA IgG
antibody and Ebner antibody as we
mentioned are frequently positive and
remain so for life with the one
exception that there are those few
individuals who are abner antibody
negative persistently for reasons that
we don't understand
this now looks at the staging of primary
EBV and assesses how we would use the
EBV specific panel of viral capsid
antigen antibody IgM class viral capsid
antigen antibody IgG class in the Edna
one antibody IgG class to make the
diagnosis of stage of primary EBV
infection so in the first instance of
EBV naive individuals of course they
have no antibody against any of these
three viral antigens in the acute
primary infection which we designate
from onset to three weeks post
expression of those symptoms we have the
VCA IgM positive the VCA IgG depending
on whether you're looking at the P 18 or
the P 23 component will frequently be
positive but Edna is always negative at
that point in sub acute infection which
we're saying is one month to three
months post onset of illness the VCA IgM
in almost all individuals will remain
positive the VCA I G G which was
possibly positive in the acute primary
infection remains positive and
essentially a hundred percent of
patients are positive now but very few
patients are Edna positive at that point
then in convalescence during the next
three months the four is six months
after onset of illness the VCA IgM may
persist but it often has waned to
undetectable levels the VCA will be
positive and the edna is becoming
positive but not in every case whereas
if we look at past infection that would
be six months or more after the primary
illness we will see that the VCA IgM has
become negative whereas the VCA IgG and
the abner are both positive
a question that remains to be answered
is is there a utility in adding an
antibody test against early antigen
diffuse would this really help us to
sort out in controversy or difficult
cases where the infection actually
occurred when the infection actually
occurred and this is something that's
worth pursuing okay here's another table
from the ASM textbook and what we're
looking at here is not primary EBV in
the immuno competent host we're looking
at EBV infections in other situations or
more significantly the area of chronic
EBV infections the first thing that we
we have listed here on the top row is
monitoring patients post transplant and
here what is most commonly done is we
look at the blood viral load I will say
that there are certain centers that
prefer to look at plasma and so the
matrix is actually a little bit in
question but I would say the majority of
centers are looking at blood viral load
and they use the amount to decide
whether they should reduce the patient's
immunosuppression whether they need to
try to to treat an acute EBV infection
or not so monitoring post transplant EB
the infections blood viral load that's
the test that's used it's usually a
real-time PCR and its quantitative the
diagnosis of post transplant
lymphoproliferative disorder is not made
by viral load or by antibody testing
specifically but rather by in situ
hybridization of biopsy material for the
detection of RNA EBV nuclear transcripts
or eber if one is dealing with hairy
leukoplakia which is a oral EBV disease
usually in subjects with very severe
immuno suppression such as
late-stage hiv/aids the diagnosis can be
made clinically because the location of
the lesions is very specific but if if
in it's a question then immune situ
hybridisation of allegiance swab or
biopsy or actually looking for DNA and
that material can be done when EBV is
suspected of causing meningoencephalitis
then pcr of the spinal fluid is the way
to go
in the case of the associated cancers
again we rely on in situ hybridization
of biopsy material for detection of EBV
RNA transcripts or Eva this is a figure
from a paper that Carol Holman in our
group published a few years ago looking
at the utility of the height of EBV
viremia
for prediction or detection of post
transplant lymphoproliferative disorder
and these were solid organ transplant
patients and and what we can see is that
in subjects who have proximate to the
time of their diagnosis of PTL d very
low viral loads less than a thousand
only two and a half percent of these
subjects developed PT LD and the
opposite is true
in the situation of high viral load of
greater than a hundred thousand copies
for Miller blood here almost a third of
the subjects developed PT LD so this is
an example of how quantitative viral
loads can be helpful in tracking the
propensity for the subjects to develop
ppl deep in transplant setting i would
now like to turn attention to one of the
issues that is very much in need
of prevention or treatment and that is
the issue of chronic EBV diseases it's
especially certain cancers and
autoimmune diseases such as multiple
sclerosis first let's remember that EBV
is the first human cancer virus Denis
Burkitt discovered Burkitt's lymphoma
back in the late 50s and then Tony
Epstein in 1964 showed that those
Burkitt lymphoma cells contained EBV but
in addition to endemic Burkitt lymphoma
EBV also causes Hodgkin's disease
lymphomas usually b-cell lymphomas but
also sometimes t-cell lymphomas in
immunocompromised hosts it causes
gastric carcinoma in approximately 10%
of cases and it is a very important
cause of cancer among individuals of
Chinese background nasopharyngeal
carcinoma one of the most common tumors
among Chinese Chinese people
how does EBV exactly wind up spurring
cancer this is a figure from David
Thorley Lawson's work that he published
a new lean journal a few years ago and
what it looks that is EBV infection in
the context of the activity of the
b-cell after it's infected and and what
is is clear is that there are several
potential areas where a block in the
normal infection cycle can lead to
malignancy in the first instance we're
looking at what would normally occur in
this direction here where EBV
would infect an ie B cell that B cell
would then become a
recognize EBV and become a memory b-cell
with memory for evv would exit the
peripheral compartment and would
basically enter a memory cell area where
it would be not pathogenic but there are
two spots here in this process that can
lead to malignancy
what is the Hodgkin's disease block
which is thought to occur when the
germinal Center b-cell tries to enter
the memory cell compartment and can't
for some reason and it just continues to
circulate and proliferate and if you
have enough of that you get a lethal
mute a malignant mutation which can go
on to become a b-cell lymphoma in the
case of Burkitt lymphoma it's a similar
situation except the block is at the
dividing memory b-cell stage to the
resting memory B so stage what we see
frequently in transplant patients this
post transplant lymphoproliferative are
a disorder that's shown up here where by
send to standard B cells are instantly
infected with EBV cytotoxic T
lymphocytes get at those bystander
b-cells and kill them but if we put on
immuno suppression in the subject to
keep the allograft attacked that immuno
suppression will either reduce the
number and the efficiency or the potency
of the seat of the SATA toxic lymphocyte
to kill the virus infected cell and it
does it and so you have circulating
blasting cells which if they become
monoclonal can result in frank
malignancy after transplantation let's
turn now to a discussion of EBV and
autoimmune diseases and the best example
we have right now I think is the
connection between Epstein Barr virus
and multiple sclerosis there is no doubt
that EBV is the major environmental risk
factor for multiple score Oh
and the evidence for that is that
essentially all MS patients have EBV
their antibodies and their antibody
levels are elevated especially against
Edna one which to me suggests that
there's virus activity going on that is
constantly stimulating an antibody
secreting cells to make this antibody
another point is that a history of mono
significantly increases the risk of
multiple sclerosis and finally
investigators have found in autopsy
tissue of MS patients who have died a
very serious progressive MS they have
found EBV and EBV active transcripts
indicating that there's EBV activity in
the neuro inflammatory tissue of the
brain and so one interesting thought
which has been expressed here in our
hypothesis by dr. Pender who is an
Australian neuroscientist
is that you have to have a certain
genetic makeup to get MS and if that's
the case and you do not control
autoreactive B cells which find lodging
in the central nervous system and then
because those cells are their antibodies
the cross-react with myelin tissue
actually then result in the plaque like
neural inflammatory lesions of multiple
sclerosis there are other diseases
literally a myriad of diseases that EBV
is in part or completely responsible for
this list is by no means complete it's
just the major ones chronic active EBV
which can be fatal in young children
chronic fatigue syndrome also known as
myalgic encephalomyelitis
subacute sclerosing excuse me uh
systemic lupus erythematosus and
rheumatoid arthritis now there also is a
whole host of diseases some of which
don't even have a name that have some of
the findings of lupus or chronic fatigue
or MS and there's no real categorization
of these but I think a common thread
through all of them is the generalized
fatigue and and in joint and muscle
involvement and all of these could
ultimately be found to be caused by EBV
I think this is a very unexplored and
very important area for future research
ok so that leads me into the last area
that I want to talk about which is the
focus now of our research and that is
prevention of primary EBV and so here is
an alternative to is it better to get
EBV when you're younger or is it better
to get EBV when you're older I would
argue that EBV vaccine could change all
of this - you don't have to pay me now
you don't have to pay me later you don't
have to pay me at all because the virus
is gone the vaccine is taken care of it
our hypothesis in our research program
now to develop an Epstein Barr virus
vaccine is that EBV v vaccine given
before primary infection will prevent or
reduce the severity of infectious mono
cancers due to EBV and multiple
sclerosis imagine with me a college
campus without mono even though it's not
reportable it's estimated that 125,000
cases are occurring among you
college students each year imagine a
cancer clinic without Hodgkin disease
there are 200,000 new cases of EBV
associated cancers including highest
rates annually worldwide imagine a world
without multiple sclerosis right now
there are more than 2 million people
living with multiple sclerosis worldwide
it's not an ice disease right now we
have two EBV vaccines that have been
tested in humans the first one I'm going
to talk about is the cd8 t-cell peptide
vaccine which is has been used to
literally induce production of EBV
specific cytotoxic lymphocytes from
naive T cells and then these EBV
specific cytotoxic lymphocytes go on to
recognize and kill EBV infected b-cells
this concept has actually been proven in
in a paper a few years ago the problem
with this vaccine however is that it's
HLA restricted which means that you
can't use it in every subject and so the
cost of producing vaccines
according to HLA type would probably
make this relatively prohibitive for a
general population okay what we're
working on is a GP 350 based vaccine and
you remember when we looked at the
little doll figure of EBV and we saw
those projections so many you probably
thought they were ears but they're
actually little groups of GP or
glycoprotein 350 which is heavily
expressed on the surface of the virus
this vaccine would induce antibody
against that commonly expressed surface
lipoprotein and what what we would then
do is we would block EBV infection
because EBV gt350 exquisitely recognized
as
twenty-one on the surface of human
b-cells and by blocking that entry spot
evv cannot attach and penetrate and
infect cells so what are we doing right
now at the University of Minnesota we
are in late stage negotiations to obtain
the cells that have been have been very
carefully engineered to optimally
produce GP 350 and also all of the
technical background material that goes
with being able to produce our own
material right now our timeline is to
finish the preclinical work on this GT
350 based vaccine in the summer and fall
of this year and if the FDA is nice to
us and hopefully they will be we would
like to initiate at least a Phase one
clinical trial in the fall of 2017 this
is an important Avenue of research for
the University of Minnesota
our Dean Brooks Jackson Dean of the
medical school and vice president for
Health Sciences has been quoted as
saying we now have the opportunity to
develop and evaluate a vaccine to
prevent EBV infection
which has the potential to save millions
of lives
I consider this research to be a top
priority in the academic health center
and so as we conclude the basically the
oral portion of our seminar I want to
leave you with my contact information my
email my office phone and the fact that
development of vaccine is a long process
and an expensive process and I would
certainly hope that some of you out
there might at least consider a donation
to our program we have the University of
Minnesota foundation we
is a 501c3 tax-exempt situation so
contributions to the University of
Minnesota foundation are 100% tax
deductible and would help us very much
to continue development of this vaccine
my highest priority as I sort of them in
the golden years maybe someone st. great
years golden years of my research
endeavors my my number one priority is
to see this vaccine in individuals I
think it would certainly reduce the
incidence and severity of infectious
mononucleosis it might prevent multiple
sclerosis I believe it would stop a lot
of EBV induced cancers especially
Hodgkins and nasopharyngeal carcinoma
and hey maybe all of those diseases that
don't even have a name but have very
severe chronic consequences for many
many many people maybe those diseases
would be reduced or eliminated by EBV
vaccine in closing I want to thank the
asuras for sponsoring this for lab
routes for all of the technical and the
presentation abilities and I want to
again thank those of you who took time
from your busy day to watch this
presentation thanks a million for
participating and I look forward to
answering some of your questions as we
have time thank you so much dr. Hague
for that informative presentation before
I get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you may
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button in the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions
live as we can it looks like we have you
so far great so our first question is so
professor Balfour you did speak to early
antigen diffuse describing a little bit
more of utility of the
antibody and the diagnosis of
mononucleosis and how all its utility be
resolved yeah certainly the thing is
that the more antibodies you test the
wider your your spectrum of information
is and so it is possible that looking at
the immune response to early antigen
diffuse would in some way distinguished
early versus middle versus late primary
be the infection but we don't have those
data and so moving forward we are hoping
to do actually a study with the asourian
to examine syrup collected at various
stages after primary be the infection to
see if the presence amount or absence of
antibody against early antigen diffuse
would be helpful in sorting out the
disease stage and progress in those
subjects results of that study so we
have a really interesting question here
so something about a reactivation of
epstein-barr virus later in life so it
does a reactivation of EBV later in life
puts you at greater risk for
autoimmunity and cancers or does being
older increase the severity of EBV
infection very very good question the
reactivation of EBV actually occurs in
everybody but it occurs frequently and
we don't yet have information that it
occurs more frequently in in older
people but I would suspect that that is
the case because a sister virus
varicella-zoster virus as we know more
commonly causes the reactivation form of
the disease namely zoster as opposed to
chickenpox in in older people and as we
see the amount of or the prevalence of
it is greatest in the older decades but
but we don't have that exact information
yet for EBV what we know about how a BB
might cause gastric cancer well we don't
understand exactly the mechanism but
what we do know is if you look at the
gastric gastric cancer cells about 10
percent of patients will have the active
EBV transcripts in those cells
Ebru positive in other words and so we
realize that EBV is actively replicating
in those cells now why certain
individuals would get gastric cancer and
then a subset of them go on to have EBV
specific cancer we don't know but but
the likelihood is that we have three
things working we have the environment
we have the host genetics and we have
the the timing and severity of the
initial EBV infection all of these
factors contribute I think to whether or
not Eve Eve is first cancer now
switching from Diagnostics to
therapeutics we have a really nice
question here is there a need for
therapeutics for epstein-barr virus
infection may be specifically
mononucleosis
are there any therapeutics available or
in development or is there an animal
model of infection for us to tests these
therapeutics yeah very
all good questions first of all to
answer the last part first no there is
no good animal model for epstein-barr
virus infection and that has been one of
the things that has slow development of
an EBD vaccine because you don't have an
ideal animal model in which to test
candidate vaccines the the role of
therapeutics is kind of a mixed bag and
in an unfortunate situation that kind of
parallels the vaccine experience and
that is development of drugs
specifically antiviral drugs against EBV
has been extremely slow and we only have
right now two drugs available a
Cyclovia or it's viola available prodrug
valet cycling gear and gancyclovir and
it's bio-available prodrug val
ganciclovir and these have never been
subjected to rigorous clinical trials
but and and so that's basically what we
have there are a few other drugs in the
pipeline
I think drugs specifically developed a
treatment cytomegalovirus which is a
sister virus infection that have
activity against EBV does EBV need to be
treated as primary EBV need to be
treated in the college student with mono
you bet if we had a good therapy it
would be certainly something that I
would prescribe and more therapeutic but
so also continuing so back to the cancer
discussion how I'll describe is the role
of EBV in the pathogenesis of
nasopharyngeal cancer and how does this
Coker do we know in the research with
human papilloma virus associated head
and neck cancer and or recurrent
respiratory papilloma ptosis any
information on the EBV really has
nothing to do with the other things
except for NPC there's a fringe of
carcinoma okay and there there's no
doubt that EBV is is causing the disease
you can find EBV there you can see
specifically antibody profiles against
EBV a hundred percent of NPC patients
have had an evening the infection
usually in childhood so the incubation
period of this is quite long I would
think that one of the group's most
interested in EBV vaccine are Chinese
both in mainland China and Taiwan
because of the fact that this is such a
common cancer and pretty clearly related
to EBV in fact the first trial it was a
small trial of EBV vaccine was done in
in Chinese subjects to try to see if it
was feasible to develop a vaccine to
prevent nasopharyngeal carcinoma
interesting we look forward to the the
next round of vaccine data hopefully
coming up in 2017 so now transitioning
from therapeutics cancer to we spoke
about multiple sclerosis and autoimmune
disease so if you have had an active
past EBV infection does that mean your
likelihood of getting multiple sclerosis
is now lower can you speak to the timing
of EBV infection and risk environmental
risk factor for MS yes the situation of
course with EBD and ms is complicated by
the fact that 90 to 95 percent of adults
have antibody against EBV the footprint
of a prior infection and yet only a
fraction of those individuals hit
multiple sclerosis but it is quite clear
that EBV is related because it is quite
apparent that those individuals who have
a multiple sclerosis like illness
without DVD antibody the diagnosis isn't
right it has to be relooked at whereas
with EBV there's data that the earlier
you get infected the the more likely you
are to go on to develop MS and these
these are data from a collaborative
international study of multiple
sclerosis among children but there are
clearly combinations of things that work
to cause MS or not and the genetic
background of the host is very important
we know that because in mono a psychotic
twins if one has MS the likelihood of
the other one getting MS it is quite a
huge amount maybe 10 times that of the
general population and then we see that
in first-degree relatives of MS patients
the risk is about three times that of
the general population and so on so so
the genetics is terribly important and
then of course there are environmental
factors which have been
explored in terms of exposure to Sun
where where you live in the world and
the incidence of MS relates to that
relates to some in some way to vitamin D
metabolism and that's going to be
interesting to explore I think among
patients with EBV diseases if vitamin D
is somehow involved in host defense
against specifically against EBV
so earlier you were infected those are
more likely you are to to to develop a
mess so somebody who gets infected later
on is probably not as as subject to
getting MS but again we don't have
absolute information on that very
interesting going back to the main seed
question you know pay me now or pay me
later
putting autoimmune diseases in that mix
is definitely a major factor so now
transitioning to the EBV vaccine so can
a vaccine be used in patients who have
already had primary EBV infection to
prevent further diseases yes a wonderful
question and we categorize vaccines
really into groups preventive vaccines
or therapy or prophylactic vaccines vs.
therapeutic vaccines and there clearly
is an effort particularly in the arena
of nasopharyngeal carcinoma to develop
therapeutic vaccines that is vaccines
that would boost the hosts immune
response even though they're already
infected but that might you know get
after the virus by stimulating the host
to be more immune aggressive against
against the virus and then there are our
efforts to basically take a person cells
out of the body expose them to viral
material to make them very specifically
recognizing that material and then give
them back this is sort of a type of
autologous
passive immunization after the
individuals been infected so yes there
are efforts foot to develop vaccines
that are therapeutic that are treatment
vaccines for evening the spur diseases
and I think we are just running out of
time so maybe we'll just have one more
question here
so do antibodies against glycoprotein
350 cross-react with myelin components
to our knowledge they do not and then
maybe just one more question here can
you speak to the value of viral load
testing versus antibody testing in the
diagnosis of primary infection maybe
from Sierra versus rifle yeah well
primary infection usually if you're
dealing with the otherwise normal hosts
there are people who have used a viral
load but it's not cost-effective in my
opinion I think the best way to look at
the normal host is going to be like I
said a header file tighter or if there's
a question about the results if you're
worried that the heterophile is slow to
develop EBV specific antibody specific
antibody against viral capsid antigen
IgM class is the way to go viral load I
would not use routinely in the non
immuno in the immuno competent host you
know compromised patients I think the
same thing sort of obtains except for
when you're monitoring them after
transplantation and there you clearly
would use viral load excellent thank you
for the wonderful discussion on BBB
Diagnostics therapeutics and a whole
host of EBV its associated diseases so
if there are no more questions I would
once again like to thank professor Hank
Balfour for his wonderful presentation
and I would also like to thank our
sponsor dias Oren for making today's
educational webcast possible and I would
just like to remind our audience the
today's web
caste is available for on-demand viewing
through for six months so through
November 17th 2016 and you will receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcam webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
Ford this announcement to your
colleagues and who may have missed
today's live event so see you next time